welcome to the weird bacterial world of
zachary kopfer who wowed the internet
with this incredible microbial portrait
of einstein
so i'm zachary kopfer i'm a bio artist
who invented the method of
bacteriography which is basically a
process to grow photographs in bacteria
i love bacteria bacteria is gorgeous
there are all these different media that
make all these different colors with
different species and it's amazing the
variety you can get and i like the idea
that there's this invisible little
universe growing all over our skin and
with this work i'm taking that universe
and bring it into our perspective and
making it visible so we can see it
but how do you take a picture using
bacteria as film
zachary uses a nutrient-rich jelly or a
growth medium to create his artworks so
initially the bacteria are spread out
evenly across these plates we can't see
them of course because they're so small
but the colonies because they have a lot
of food here they're going to start to
grow then he takes a transparent sheet
with einstein's picture on it and he
shines ultraviolet light down
now the bacteria that are not shaded
from light are going to be hit by
ultraviolet rays which will damage their
dna and cause them to not be able to
reproduce but the bacteria that are
underneath the black parts are shielded
from ultraviolet light and they can
reproduce just fine
bacteria is essentially invisible to us
what better way to see it than in your
own portrait
i look at everything in life through the
perspective of science to me science is
beautiful sciences art science is poetry
and this work is a way for me to
translate my perspective into a visual
artifact for other people to actually
see
i wish i had my picture in bacteria but
he can do that we can get him to do that
now
we can help with that
i hope you like it adam